Let’s say it’s a lovely Tuesday evening, and
you’re out there living your best life, building a
new commander deck from the comfort of your couch.
You start by finding cards—maybe they’re from
EDHRec, maybe they’re from Scryfall searches, and
maybe they’re from your friend Brad who happens
to be an expert on four-toughness creatures.
Regardless, you’re finding lots of cool stuff
for your deck, and you’re tossing them into some
sort of deckbuilding website, watching them neatly
segregate themselves by type before your eyes.
This is fine at first, but over time things start
to get a bit muddier—you know the numbers of the
card types, which will be helpful for some decks,
but additional information is hard to come by.
What if you need to know how much low-cost ramp
you have to decide on how many higher-mana cards
you can support? What if you need to know how many
cards allow you to cast things from outside your
hand for the purposes of Flaming Tyrannosaurus?
What if you’re trying to make sure you have the
right number of things to slow down opponents,
and protect what you’ve got? This is where
categorizing starts to become really useful—you
can lump a specific group of cards into their own
little bucket and keep track of them that way.
Though a lovely tool on the surface, categories
can range a bit in their usefulness—they can be
a helpful tool in deckbuilding, but they can just
as easily add more confusion than they elucidate,
or even lead players down unfortunate deckbuilding
paths all on their own. So, in this video I want
to talk about what categories accomplish,
and how to get the most utility out of them
in deckbuilding, as well as how some people are
setting back their own decks by using them wrong.
Before bumming you out with that, though, I want
to tell you about something exciting—it’s this
video’s sponsor, Voidmonster. Voidmonster.org
is a site started by MTG artist Forrest Imel—who
you may know from the original Dockside, rest
in peace—and it features some really punchy,
evocative designs for trading card game
accessories. There’s the awesome cycle
of mana symbol playmats, and there’s also
an exclusive new drop once a month that’s
available for a week long preorder period but
gone after that. This month is the Greedy drop—a
Pot of Greed shirt and playmat, with an added
gold-foiled treasure token if you get both,
and you can preorder that until July
6th. You can check that out at the
link in the description, and thanks to
Voidmonster for sponsoring this video.
Okay, so the first thing categories do is capture
the core tasks that the cards in your deck are
performing, and allow you to look specifically at
these subsets. I always start out with categories
of card that most decks will want at least some
of—principally lands, ramp, draw, protection,
and interaction. These categories are useful
because all on their own they can start to
paint a picture of the shape of what a deck is
doing. If a deck runs a lot of lands and ramp,
I know I’m going to be looking at a beefy midrange
deck that’s looking to outscale its opponents.
If I see a deck that’s lower on cards intended
to interact with opposing plays and higher on
protection, I know I’m looking at something that’s
going to be faster and more proactive. I’m going
to get more into constructing these categories and
when to break them up, but first I want to lay out
a cautionary note. I’ve seen a lot of guides
recommending people include a category such
as “theme” as a discrete entity alongside these
other sorts of function categories, at least in
the early stages of deckbuilding, and I simply
can’t recommend that as a general practice. This
is a somewhat misleading piece of advice because
in most successful decks, a large number of these
“theme” cards will also be accomplishing the other
core tasks I mentioned earlier—mana acceleration,
value generation, protection, and ways to
slow opponents. There may be some cards that
do only their theme, such as 1 mana birds in a
Sephara deck or Merfolk lords in a Hakbal deck,
but a whole lot of other theme cards will often be
contributing to one of these core categories. If
somebody asked me for healthy starting ranges for
their core categories for a bog-standard EDH deck,
I’d say something like 35-40 lands,
15-20 pieces of removal-equivalent,
13-18 pieces of draw, 7-12 pieces of ramp,
and 3-8 pieces of protection. What you might
notice about that is that if you go on the
higher end of each of those values to be safe,
that adds up to 98 deck slots—you got a whole one
leftover to work with. This is not to say that you
necessarily need those numbers in every deck, or
that there won’t be overlap, but the implication
here is that cards that don’t fit into one of
these categories are inherently charging your
deck an opportunity cost, and you should keep that
in mind when deciding how many of them to have.
With that out of the way for now, let’s
get into the meat of these core categories,
because there can be nuances in what a category
should cover. Lands are the simplest, because the
deckbuilding role—lands—generally matches up
1-to-1 with the card type of land. You could
make an exception for non-mana-producing lands
such as Glacial Chasm or specific centerpiece
lands like Maze’s End, since these won’t be
producing mana as their primary function,
but for most other cards I’d keep them
categorized as a land first and foremost,
with any other functions entered as subcategories
I can look at later. In this case, the utility of
including or excluding lands from your “lands”
category comes from how you use that category—as
long as the cards in your lands category are
cards that you personally consider a land drop,
you can do some math on the resulting number and
figure out how successful you’ll be at making it
up to your higher-costed spells. Speaking of
making it up to higher-costed spells, let’s
talk about ramp. This is one of the trickier core
categories because it can vary so much—most decks
want some of it, some decks want a lot of it, and
a handful of decks won’t want much at all. So,
when constructing your ramp category, you should
be asking yourself “why am I ramping?” If your
ramp is geared to hit specific cards a turn early,
you’ll want to be specific with the curve of your
mana, and it might even be worth including
ritual-style cards that give temporary mana
in some circumstances. By contrast, if your ramp
is generally geared toward increasing the volume
of your mana without specific timing goals,
less card-efficient options like smaller ramp
and ritual-style cards won’t make as much sense,
and bigger options will likely work out. You’ll
sometimes catch me saying something like “Worn
Powerstone isn’t a ramp spell if you’re playing
a Krenko deck” because it’s fun to speak in quippy
absolutes, but what I really mean when I say that
is that if your acceleration category is mainly
intended to get you to four mana a turn early,
Worn Powerstone doesn’t fit that function,
and thus it probably isn’t worth playing.
The same goes for interaction, which I
choose to define here as cards that exist
to set back opponents in some way. The card
Murder performs one game action—destroying
a creature—but this game action can accomplish a
number of different tasks: killing a big attacker,
clearing out a blocker, stopping a combo, taking
care of a value engine, eliminating a stax piece,
and so on. This fact gets a bit more puzzling
when we consider that there are lots of cards
that perform some of these tasks, and often better
than a Murder can, but can’t perform others.
Fogs are great defensively and even against some
combos, but are useless for slowing opponents
down. Counterspells will be good at protection
and combo breaking, but the timing will restrict
their usefulness in limiting opposing value, and
they can’t deal with things already in play. Your
instinct might be to back away from this fact and
pretend that it doesn’t exist, but for purposes of
categorization all this means is that, in lieu of
perfectionism, we can focus on building categories
that are flexible, and work with our deck’s needs.
One categorical starting point I’ve used before is
having two slightly-fuzzy buckets—protection +
counterspells, and removal + defense. This might
sound odd at first, but it makes some sense if
you think about all interaction in terms of how
proactive vs reactive it is. Protection is very
proactive in the sense that it purely supports
your own gameplan and involves thinking ahead
toward possible issues, and counterspells are
similar but with a bit more flexibility to hit
opposing threats. Removal of all types will be a
bit more reactive since it often gets played after
a problem card has resolved, though since it can
target value engines it could still play more of
a calculated, long-term role in a deck. Defensive
cards like attack and damage prevention are the
most reactive in my mind since they’re a thing
whose only purpose is preventing a player from
losing—the final line of defense in an EDH game.
With these different types of cards laid
out, the two-buckets approach basically
just draws an arbitrary line somewhere
in the middle of this spectrum of tools,
though it might be useful to get more specific.
If you have a deck that cares about a particular
interactive tool like defense or stax to hinder
things that might otherwise give you problems,
give it a category. If you have a deck that
cares about protection, definitely give it
a category—it’ll be important to keep an eye
on. Putting this extra thought into categories
will also give you a better idea of what your deck
does or doesn’t need. I’ll often include graveyard
exile in a removal, stax, or general interaction
category, because most decks won’t gain anything
by granting this necessary tool its own category.
This won’t be the case for all decks, though—my
Malfegor deck has three separate categories for
its interaction suite because they all serve
different roles—discard effects put my opponents
behind in value, removal deals with active threats
on the board, and graveyard exile serves an
unusual key role here in preventing opponents
with graveyard oriented decks from getting use
out of the cards I’m causing them to discard.
On the other hand, if different interaction pieces
aren’t serving clearly defined roles that you want
to keep an eye on, it might be perfectly fine to
throw them together into the same category—it all
depends on how much you care about distinguishing
somewhat-different effects from one another.
The same is true for draw to a lesser extent. If
you have a bunch of normal card draw in your deck,
you might call that category “draw”. If you add in
some handful of draw-adjacent things like Laelia
or Future Sight, those are probably also fine in
that draw category as long as you’re not a Queza
player, though you could also rename the category
to value or something—the name isn’t too relevant.
What is relevant is when different draw-adjacent
cards start to perform different tasks. In my draw
video I laid out that various things that allow
a player to see and play with more cards can be
placed along a continuum based on how much of a
player’s library they allow you to see. In the
middle is ordinary draw—seeing as many cards as
it acquires—and on the edges are pure filtering
spells which generate no card advantage, and
pure value cards which don’t even interact with
a player’s library. In some cases all of these
can be lumped into the same category—tutors,
card draw, recursion, and so on, but other times
different cards might start to take on different
roles. You might run tutors or filtering spells
to allow you to find the tools to build some sort
of central engine for your deck, and in that
case you might want to keep the digging cards
and the value cards in different categories to
keep an eye on how many you’ve got of each. And
that’s just a case where categories might be
nice—depending on how you’re building value,
it might be essential to lay out more clear roles.
Some decks might run a bunch of draw-discard
looting cards as their card selection to find
what they need, and also some recursion or
other graveyard synergies as their sources of
value to get an advantage over their opponents.
In that case, those two things are going to
be playing quite distinct roles in your deck,
to the point where they basically become
a whole separate thing—a synergy package.
This is the second major thing categories
do—allowing people to keep track of synergies.
Specifically, for each synergy package I’ll
include two categories—setup, and payoff. As
an example—in a flicker deck I have, I include
a “core cards” category that includes my three
flicker engines plus a card that increases
the overall velocity of the deck, and I also
include a category called “Mmmm, tasty slide” that
features creatures with ETBs that I might want to
repeat through flickering. Relevantly, the former
category is a primary category, because pushing
my flicker gameplan is the only thing these
cards accomplish, whereas the other category
is a sub-category that I don’t need to see all
the time. This is because being flickerable isn’t
the primary role of these cards, it’s simply an
attribute about them—the fact that they have an
ETB that it’s useful to repeat is only a relevant
fact when I have an Astral Slide effect available,
and their role is typically the same in either
case, just amplified if they’re being flickers.
There might be other situations where both setup
and payoff are in their own sub-categories,
or where these things are layered into different
categories—whatever ends up making the most sense
to you. Regardless, the utility that the
categories are creating for you in this
case is allowing you to keep an eye on how well
supported a specific theme is. It’s easy to throw
a flicker-Thassa into your deck after spotting
a couple cool ETBs, or toss in a Faldorn to go
along with a cool impulse-draw equipment. In
some cases these payoff cards might have enough
support from other cards to feel valuable, but in
other cases they might not. If you don’t maintain
a setup category for this synergy in your deck,
you might not even clock this as a problem and
might presume that these cards not working out
in games is due to bad luck. If you’d that setup
category and noticed that you’re only running five
pieces of impulse draw, suddenly you’d probably be
a lot more vigilant of how these cards are doing
in games, and more willing to re-evaluate them.
Some of the older usages of categories have
become a bit less necessary as deckbuilders
have picked up a particular feature—the
search function. If you’re on Archidekt,
you can throw a scryfall search in this box
here, and it’ll only show you the cards in
your deck that fit this search, which is useful
for keeping track of something like my cycling
cards in my Sharuum deck. Moxfield has something
similar—there’s this little highlighter thing
that you can throw some inputs into and it’ll
highlight all the cards that fit that definition.
Either of these might suit your preferences
based on what sorts of UI you like,
but something I like about Archidekt specifically
is how this works with the maybeboard of a deck.
Sometimes if I’m building a deck and I’m not
sure what direction I want to take it in,
I won’t stop at categorizing what’s in the
deck—I’ll categorize my maybeboard as well.
Oftentimes this category will be the reason a card
isn’t in the deck—a lot of times I’ll have a “too
expensive” category if I’m building a budget deck,
or a “too slow” category if a card is a bit below
the power level I think I’m shooting for. This
allows me to have a suite of cards available to
peruse if I later decide to power up or power down
the deck, and also acts as a form of documentation
of my thought process I can go back to. The
other type of maybeboard category I’ll include is
packages that I’m thinking of adding to the deck
but don’t know if there’s enough support for yet,
such as ETBs or Shamans. This is where the search
comes in handy—if I notice I’m ending up with a
lot of top of library manipulation, I can plug
a search term like “shuffle” or “library” into
the box and I’ll immediately see how many cards
in different categories and maybeboard packages
include that term. As a final note here, searches
won’t always perfectly capture the stuff that
might be included in a category. If I searched
“enter” into my Sharuum Slide flicker deck,
among the things that pop up would be Vedalken
Aethermage and Eagles of the North, two cards
whose ETB is decidedly not the reason they’re
in the deck. Still, search-filtering is a useful
tool and I’d definitely encourage checking
it out if the deckbuilder you use has them.
So, I’ve laid out the main two purposes
for categories in my book—grouping your
core categories to keep an eye on the shape of
your deck, and keeping track of your synergy
packages to have an idea of how thoroughly
supported different elements are. Some people
have a tendency to treat categories as a means to
appease some abstract cardboard god, but truly,
whatever works best for you in conceptualizing
your deck is the right thing to do. That said,
before I get too kumbaya with things, it’s
probably a good idea to reiterate some best
practices for the average EDH player. I laid out
some examples of what you could do or what you
should do, but what shouldn’t you do? For one,
putting cards together in the same categories
that are similar on some superficial level,
but very different in function. I don’t have
an issue with combining somewhat different effects
so long as they perform roughly the same function,
so for example Expedition Map and Dark Ritual
are very different effects, but they might share
the functionality of helping a mono black player
build up to some higher-costed plays, and that’s
a valid category. An example of what wouldn’t
work is putting Thalia, Guardian of Thraben and
Ghostly Prison together in a stax category. These
cards both impose taxes, but the game actions they
tax are basically polar opposites—Thalia’s good
for slowing more technical decks and giving the
upper hand to a creature-based gameplan, whereas
Ghostly Prison makes attacking more costly but
does absolutely nothing to slow anything
outside combat. The former is proactive,
while the latter is purely reactive, and merging
them into one category is a recipe for confusion.
The other thing to avoid is overcategorizing,
basically creating a category to track a type
of card that isn’t actually useful to track. I’ll
sometimes track lifegain in my grindier decks, and
even though this category often only contains only
a couple cards, it still feels worthwhile because
drawing a piece of lifegain in something like
my Malfegor deck typically feels like a dramatic
shift of dynamic for the deck. On the other hand,
I would never create a category like this for an
aggressive deck with a strong proactive plan—Senu
is a solid lifegain engine in my Yoshimaru deck,
but the lifegain isn’t why I added the card and
drawing into a source of lifegain doesn’t really
impact the decisionmaking of something that is,
first and foremost, a beatdown deck. The same goes
for another card in that Yoshi deck—Six. I’d call
this a recursion spell generally, but it’s not in
the deck because I need recursion, it’s in the
deck because it’s a solid source of value that’s
also legendary. In another deck with stronger
graveyard themes I might have given it a more
specific category, but in this deck I’ve opted
to simply stick it with the deck’s card draw,
where it feels right at home. Now, these are
instances where categorizing a card differently
could add unneeded complexity to a deck’s
categories, to over-explain what the cards in
a deck do. This is kind of a problem on its own,
but the bigger issue with over-categorization is
when categories are used to justify the presence
of cards that really might not belong in a deck.
Let’s say I’m building my Yoshimaru deck, and I
give Senu a lovely little lifegain category. Maybe
a bit unnecessary, but fine, whatever. Now let’s
say I see a Soul Warden hanging around in a binder
and decide to give it a spin in the deck—and hey,
we can toss that in the lifegain category as well.
Soul Warden is a powerful card that can gain a
lot of life, but it doesn’t do much in a legendary
creatures beatdown deck, because lifegain isn’t
a priority there. Without the lifegain category
I’d be forced to look at the card and go “wait,
why is this here, what is this accomplishing,”
but instead, with this category I’ve constructed
a justification for this card out of thin air,
and might choose to keep this unnecessary card
in my deck as a result. This illustrates a side
benefit of categorizing a deck—putting cards into
categories requires a deckbuilder to think about
why a card is there, and any cards that didn’t
end up in many categories immediately become
suspect and deserving of additional scrutiny.
This is one of the reasons I’m wary of “plan”
or “theme” categories—they give an easy place
to toss cards that might otherwise seem out of
place or underjustified. The problem here is the
harmful mental shortcutting this category enables,
although it actually doesn’t have to. I was
watching another creator’s recent video on
categories, and in that video Commander Baumi
is a bit more sympathetic to a plan category
in general, but mentions a specific type of
card to keep an eye on—“plan-only cards”,
or cards that fit into a deck’s central plan or
theme but don’t accomplish a whole lot else. I
found this perspective interesting, so I actually
ended up recording a long chat with Baumi where we
compared and contrasted our views on categories a
bit, and I think it’s interesting to consider how
deckbuilding style informs what categorization
practices end up working out the best. You can
check out that full conversation over on my
newly created second channel, Sal2brious,
though I’ve also included a portion
of that conversation starting… now!